a u.s. Coast Guard lieutenant accused of
being a domestic terrorist is expected
in a Maryland Court later today
Christopher Hassan is his name and
self-described white nationalist was
arrested on Friday prosecutors say he
wanted to murder innocent civilians on a
scale rarely seen he is accused of
having an apparent hit list that
includes prominent Democrats and TV
personalities David Martin news that the
Pentagon was more on this story David
good morning good morning at the age of
49 lieutenant Christopher Hasson was an
obscure Coast Guard purchasing officer
but but court documents say he was
laying plans to use his hate to make a
lasting impression on this world Ison
drafted an email saying I am dreaming of
a way to kill almost every last person
on the earth through biological attacks
and a bombing and sniper campaign a
search of his basement residence turned
up 15 firearms and more than one
thousand rounds of ammunition
Maria courious is Hassan's neighbor in
Silver Spring Maryland Hassan who once
served in the Marine Corps also kept a
hit list that reads like a who's who of
liberal politics Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi Senate Democratic leader
Chuck Schumer senator Kirsten Gillibrand
presidential candidates Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris and Cory Booker Haasan's
internet searches included best place in
DC to see Congress people and our
Supreme Court justices protected his
list also included well-known news
personalities Joe Scarborough Chris
Hayes Don Lemon and Chris Cuomo this is
a scary this is something that the
people who get named we have to deal
with especially with our family
according to court documents Hasson read
the writings of a Norwegian domestic
terrorist named Anders Breivik who in
2011 went on a rampage killing 77
Norwegians many of them teenaged summer
campers Breivik wrote about using
steroids to turn himself into a
superhuman
man army the search of Hassan's
apartment turned up over 30 bottles of
human growth hormone when Hassan appears
in court later today
federal prosecutors are expected to
argue he is too dangerous to be let out
on bail while waiting for his trial to
begin Fiona
thank goodness they caught him before
the terror began David thank you